when we set out on our roadmap to
freedom
a few months ago we were determined to
make progress that was cautious
but irreversible and step by step thanks
to the
enormous efforts of the british people
and the spectacular
vaccine rollout we now have one of the
most
open economies and societies in europe
and as we've always known and as the
february roadmap
explicitly predicted this opening up
over the last three steps has
inevitably been accompanied by more
infection and more hospitalization
because
we must be clear that we cannot simply
eliminate
covid we must learn to live with it
and with every day that goes by we're
better protected by the vaccines
and we're better able to live with the
disease
vaccination greatly reduces transmission
and
two doses provide a very high degree of
protection against
serious illness and death but there are
still
millions of younger adults who have not
been vaccinated
and sadly a proportion of the elderly
and vulnerable
may still succumb even if they have had
two jabs and that's why we're so
concerned
by the delta variant that is now
spreading faster
than the third wave that was predicted
in the february
road map we're seeing cases growing by
about
64 per week and in the worst affected
areas
it's doubling every week and the average
number of people being admitted to
hospital
in england has increased by 50 week on
week and by
61 percent in the northwest
which may be the shape of things to come
because we know the remorseless logic of
exponential growth and even if the link
between infection and hospitalization
has been weakened
it hasn't been severed and even if the
link between hospitalization
and death has also been weakened
i'm afraid numbers in intensive care in
icu
are also rising and so
we've obviously faced a very difficult
choice we can
simply keep going with all of step four
on june
the 21st even though there is a real
possibility
that the virus will outrun the vaccines
and that thousands more deaths would
ensue that could otherwise have been
avoided or else
we can give the nhs a few more crucial
weeks to get
those remaining jabs into the arms of
those who need them
and since today i cannot say that we
have met
all our four tests for proceeding with
step four
on june the 21st i think it is sensible
to wait just a little longer
by monday the 19th of july we will aim
to have double jabbed around two-thirds
of the adult population including
everyone over 50 all the vulnerable
all frontline health and care workers
and everyone over 40
who received their first dose by mid-may
and to do this we will now accelerate
the second jabs for those over 40
just as we did for the vulnerable groups
so they get
the maximum protection as fast as
possible
and we will bring forward our target to
give every adult in this country
a first dose by the 19th of july
that is including young people over the
age of
18 with 23 and 24 year olds
invited to book jabs from tomorrow
so we reduce the risk of transmission
among the groups
that mix the most
and to give the nhs
that extra time we will hold off
step four openings until july the 29th
except for weddings that can still go
ahead
with more than 30 guests provide
provided social distancing
remains in place and the same
will apply to wakes and we will continue
to pilot events such as euro 2020
and some theatrical performances
we will monitor the position every day
and if
after two weeks we have concluded that
the risk has diminished
then we reserve the possibility of
proceeding
to step four and a full opening sooner
as things stand and on the evidence
that i can see right now i'm confident
that we will not need
more than four weeks and we won't need
to go beyond july the 19th
it's unmistakably clear the vaccines
are working and the sheer scale
of the vaccine rollout has made our
position incomparably better
than in previous waves but now
is the time to ease off the accelerator
because by being cautious now
we have the chance in the next four
weeks to save
many thousands of lives by vaccinating
millions more people and once the adults
of this company
have been overwhelmingly vaccinated
which is what we can achieve
in a short space of time we will be in a
far
stronger position to keep
hospitalizations down
to live with this disease and
to complete our cautious but
irreversible road map
to freedom